[Musica]
ragazzi già morto
ragazzi anzi notte qualche soldo
quello mio ma che cosa hai fatto ma ho
fatto quello che mi hai detto di farlo
io ti avevo detto crocifiggerli cavolo
io ho capito croci finiti ma che pare
era lì lì i mariti detto porta la croce
sulle spalle e taglie la fiorentina mi
senti mai non capisce ma niente ma
perché vuoi distruggere gli umani parla
perché lo stanno facendo già da soli o
c'è un progetto invece che un no si
chiamerà 16 o ma se accesso secondo me
funziona
papà io invece credo che le cose si
sistemeranno o tocca del cuore di morte
precisamente della cella anche trovare
un modo per smettere di farli
moltiplicare come ricci ed imitare il
problema della sovrapposizione ultima
cena crocifissione resurrezione ho
bisogno di riposo
sono stanco morto trovato luna per anni
centrali dovranno dovranno farsi una
critica costruttiva ha fatto da solo un
genio ei sveglia quanto turni da duemila
anni buon dio buon me ma cosa è successo
in 2000 anni o niente
poi virato in giro ricordi la termine
e meravigliosa vero uno dei miei lavori
migliori cinque giorni per mettere in
piedi questa meraviglia e poi il sesto
devo essermi affaticati
non è così diversa da come la ricordavi
a te l'ho detto
gli uomini sono diventati persone
migliori se ci fai caso però ci sono
delle forme quelle differenze e
sinceramente non noto nulla di diverso
ma sì ma certo scusate ma scusi sa che
cosa stai facendo e che cos'è quel carro
senza cavallo una macchina figlio mio
e vuoi sapere che cosa serve non credo
gli esseri umani l'hanno inventata per
muoversi più velocemente ma non è questa
la chicca per quale aspetta che la metto
in modo così ti faccio vedere pensano di
essere invisibili
fondamentalmente la macchina serve
all'uomo per fargli credere di muoversi
più velocemente ma allo stesso tempo
senti questi bei gas lo uccide ma quindi
per ogni passo avanti ne fanno due
indietro e vedere qualcosa di più
orribile ricordi la tigre del caspio
il picco imperiale il toto certo dove
sono resistenti e la foca monaca dei
caraibi estinta e la il cefalo bufale
estinto ti prego non dirmi che al triste
co capufficio estinto anch'esso male
oppure moltiplicare in compenso hanno
creato lui ma è bellissimo
non è orribile verona pensa che alcuni
di questi sono più importanti dell'umano
tipo mai mediafriends
a cosa serve tanta dolcezza a fare
l'unica cosa che sa fare cose stupide
mentre li fai foto col cellulare
questo è il cellulare ma siamo a casa
sua ci penso io sono dio non avere paura
di cosa stavi facendo
e allora a che cosa hai fatto
questo è il telefono gli umani l'hanno
creato per chiamarsi ma fondamentalmente
lo usano per non parlar sia fatto riposi
papà
[Risate]
che stai fargli il cadavere ci guarda
provalo anche tu
ma che senso ha questa diavoleria questo
accetto
basta non per cento che senso ha creare
cellulari degli spari ma no papà perché
mi ha portato qui lo ricordi cosa è
successo al dodo all'alce solo bufale e
alte coca pupo fish
questo è uno dei motivi che cosa
munnizza il mondo ne è pieno di
inquinamento di sporcizia
in una parola mummie chi guarda con i
tuoi stessi occhi figlio l'uomo si dà
delle regole al solo scopo di infrangere
quello che stanno facendo alla loro casa
è una vera vergogna macchine plastica fa
bene e tutta quella pubblicità sulle
emorroidi questo santo
interrompo perbacco guardano mahjong è
in fiamme
i ghiacciai si sciolgono specie animali
si estinguono tra cui il meraviglioso
temo kabul papa credo che in realtà si
ricade copa a buffet non mi interessa
che copre più carino e comunque questo
non ha fermato domani dall ucciderlo o
meno pericolose o gabon e penso che il
prossimo sarà noi questo tener bookshop
appartenente alla nobile razza del
pancione papa si dice van gaal non mi
interessa guardare basa questo fatto in
ridere rompuy capito cosa intendeva il
mondo va a rotoli
le guerre vestono questo pianeta come
rispondi ni pronti tutti meritevoli
non violenza corruzione e buchi
nell'ozono e altri buchi di conti voglio
parlare figlio mio presto santo
intendevo per giove anche se non l'ho
mai stimato e l'uomo continua a
prendersi in giro pensando che il vero
torto venga fattura il pianeta non
sapendo che il pianeta
sopravviverà
[Musica]
è terribile lo so guarda per esempio
quelli incivile e poi cosa succederà
quando sarà troppo tardi arriverà il
momento predestinato quale l'ora in cui
gli umani si distruggeranno l'uno con
l'altro
ma nel mondo tornerà un solo possente
essere il capo fasciato capone cha cha
cha cha deco capo liscia